I need you to stay away in the movie
there's this idea of that rachel has of
the couple that she sees and that they
must be this perfect couple and then
they're not is there such thing as a
perfect couple
yes I mean I think there's there's
couples that can work really well
together you know I know the projection
of a perfect couple of course is you
know an entirely other thing the way
Emily sees this couple in the movie
she's fantasizing she's in a desperate
and depressed place
so she's fantasizing I think to escape
her own life and see what you know that
perfect couple is you know cheap and
it's completely wrong it's all
projection you know as it is with any
time you're on a subway and looking at
someone you go no but I know where they
live what kind of music they like in a
bit you know I could you make a million
assumptions but it's all inaccurate you
know again it's just projections so yeah
I think you know there's no such thing
as a perfect couple but there's couples
that can be good together what makes you
and Jennifer so good together
I don't know we I think we appreciate
each other's sense of humor we respect
one another and and we get along you
know I mean it sounds simple but it's
true yeah it does sound simple and it
makes me think oh gosh why couldn't all
the rest of us just the human condition
you know